[Música]
llega la hora de la revista de prensa
con el rosa pérez más de buenos días
rosa buenos días han creado vamos a
comenzar hablando de los titulares en
los medios franceses por esta polémica
iniciativa llamada la primaria popular
que pretende unir a todos los candidatos
de izquierda para tener uno solo que se
enfrente a manuel macro exactamente esta
era la idea inicial de esta iniciativa
ciudadana que como comenta se pretendía
que algún alguno de los candidatos de la
izquierda llegar a poder rivalizar
eventualmente contra el actual
presidente emmanuel macrón en las
elecciones presidenciales de abril
porque recordemos que la izquierda
francesa ahora por ahora está dividida
entre el partido comunista
ecologistas la francia y sumisa y de
momento dos candidatas del partido
socialista entonces la idea inicial de
esta iniciativa como decíamos era pues
que las bases digamos que la población
se inscribiera para mostrar claramente
su apoyo a uno de los candidatos de
izquierda ahora bien lo que sucede es
que tres a digamos de los candidatos
fuertes de la izquierda esto es a ella
look de nación de la francia insee anna
hidalgo del partido socialista y yannick
jadot de los ecologistas han ya
asegurado que no van a reconocer el
resultado de esta primaria popular a
pesar de que son elegibles entre la
población que se ha inscrito pues para
participar de esta primaria ellos ya han
dicho que a pesar de que no salgan
elegidos pues van a seguir adelante con
sus candidaturas para las presidenciales
quien de momento sí dice que va a
reconocer los resultados es la que fuera
ministra de justicia durante el gobierno
de hollande socialista que es cristian
tu vida y ella de momento pues como
decíamos es una de las candidatas del
partido socialista y ella así ha dicho
que pues reconocería estos resultados y
de momento es una de las favoritas en
todo caso la elección empieza hoy va a
durar hasta el domingo y seguro angela
que vamos a comentar los resultados el
lunes seguramente lo hablamos la próxima
semana vamos a seguir en europa la
noticia a la que hemos dado más
seguimiento por reacciones políticas es
el conflicto ucrania rusia y ahora usted
no se detrae el resumen de un reportaje
que un lado más humano una re visita a
la ciudad de kharkiv fue dada por la
versión en inglés del medio alemana 'der
spiegel' exacto es un reportaje del inah
berge vélez que va a esta ciudad que
está a escasos kilómetros de la frontera
con rusia donde conviven una importante
comunidad lusófona así como desplazados
internos de la anterior episodio bélico
tras la anexión de crimea y en total son
15 millones de habitantes que viven en
esta ciudad y entre ellos corre el temor
de que eventualmente ante un ataque ruso
pues a la zona se convierta en el campo
de combate
concretamente este reportaje habla con
tres mujeres entre ellas una joven
diseñadora gráfica de 27 años ekaterina
pereverzeva que explica que ella apenas
se escucha o lee las noticias porque le
genera todavía más ansiedad y más estrés
del que ya siente de por sí y tal y como
reza el artículo dice que la joven
espera y teme el fin de la guerra a
partes iguales y citan a ekaterina que
dice lo imaginamos como un cuento de
hadas que luego todos lloran de alegría
y se abrazan pero la vida tras la guerra
puede ser más difícil que durante la
guerra y la joven se pregunta cómo se
reconciliaran los distintos grupos del
país nos lo preguntamos todos rosa y
para el cierre el presidente de la fifa
gianni infantino hace unas declaraciones
polémicas por decirlo menos en su
defensa de que se celebre en los
mundiales en menos de cuatro años exacto
y precisamente ayer generó pues eso
mucha polémica que llenó los titulares
de alrededor del mundo porque llegó a
relacionar el hecho de que el mundial de
fútbol se celebre cada dos años con él a
dar más esperanza a las personas
africanas que llegan incluso a perder la
vida intentando llegar a europa pues por
vía marítima de hecho si te parece
angela veamos las imágenes donde hace
este comentario
bonito fine ways to include the world to
give up' necesitamos encontrar maneras
de incluir a todo el mundo para dar
esperanza a los africanos para que no
tengan que cruzar el mediterráneo para
encontrar quizás una vida mejor pero más
probablemente la muerte en el mar
necesitamos dar oportunidades y dignidad
no con caridad sino permitiendo que el
resto del mundo participe quizás el
mundial cada dos años no es la respuesta
pero lo discutimos lo debatimos
el
camino de huesca
entonces cuáles son los titulares bien
pues angela en para resumir un poco pues
por ejemplo el medio deportivo olé de
argentina dice la polémica defensa de
infantino al mundial cada dos años una
vida digna para los africanos el equipo
de francia dice según gianni infantino
una copa del mundo cada dos años daría
esperanza a los africanos o la cadena
ser de españa dice infantino aclara que
sus palabras
fueron mal interpretadas dice hay
responsabilidad de mejorar la situación
o que se dijeron males gracias a usted
rosa y nos vemos son más adelante para
más titulares